hello there reject nation I'm Greg Alba
I'm John Humphrey we're gonna talk about
movie franchises the cornerstone of all
great cinema mm-hmm
lays here top reward to your video
request comes from a man named Michael B
Omni media you should go check out his
channel people he said when should a
franchise stop being a franchise or why
our current franchise is struggling to
develop new characters without killing
or removing their legacy characters is
it hard to have though he knows how to
make a good title for for a good
thumbnail and when you upload we're
gonna is all in the title is it that
hard to have the legacy characters
around and develop a character that can
step out of their shadow and stand on
their own without it being at the
expense of the people that came before
well John what are your thoughts on this
oh man it's a big issue I mean at first
I feel like when it comes to stopping
franchises that's a great question and I
feel like Terminator is slowly showing
us the answer to that it's when I think
you've struggled to start you know
momentum again and it just keeps kind of
failing or you keep getting met with the
same response you know it's like the
last three Terminator films have been
met with the same sort of lackluster
response the newest one is getting
decreasing returns and they keep making
similar promises about going back to the
glory days of things so I'm I don't know
I feel like they should let a franchise
go if they're not willing to adjust it
any and we've done it so many times that
there's nothing fresh about it like I
guess that's kind of a vague thing to
say but I think you should stop making
franchises when they're not making as
much money it's really a business sure
there's artistry inside of filmmaking
but at the end of the day it's about
making money
so if they're not making money
anymore can it plain and simple just
stop right there
because that's really the only thing you
can do at that point right if it's gonna
keep making money keep making them
because clearly numbers are the thing
that speak louder than anything else
more than a rotten tomato score more
than a cinema score it's about the
box-office returned because then we know
if people are willing to pay to go keep
watching that's what keeps movies alive
money on a serious note only ended when
it stops making money podcasts is
complete podcast is done you know or I
guess I would say when you're not when
when filmmakers feel like okay there's
there's two obvious answers I think one
obvious answer is when the franchise
clearly wanted to end that's when you
should end it it's plain and simple when
whoever helmed this original idea or
gave birth to an adaptation then it's
like The Dark Knight right like clearly
Christopher Nolan wanted to end it so
let it end and sure they have Pirates of
the Caribbean they see the thing with
there are certain movies that you have
to factor in the world of it all because
some worlds can lend itself to franchise
expansion or different world exploration
something like that I think about the
prom a lot of franchises often run into
is they want to just repeat the same
beats from the prior movies and they
think by rehashing familiarity that that
is sufficient enough when I think a lot
of the time what makes something
exciting is when you actually commit to
taking it in a new direction not kill
off the characters from old and then
replace them with new faces that are
slightly different mostly doing the same
things yeah like I think this soft
reboot thing is dull now it's very
boring to me it's like does there not
anything different it's just like
there's a slightly tweak get enough so
you don't call it a remake that's pretty
much what it is I it's like the
terminator world I think if we're
talking about every franchise is unique
to its own but it's like when Ridley
Scott came back with Prometheus people
were excited about that and we wanted to
see a different world and it was
different than the alien films it's just
the film in it of itself wasn't all that
great and that's where the problem was
and then when they did alien covenant I
was like oh I was gonna really you know
not and not commit to this but I think
John I think that's why the MCU is so
damn good is because they keep enough of
the same ingredients but they know how
to really John Ross place or take a
really different approach and I think
even Nolan did that with the Dark Knight
films he had his Batman Begins movie and
they needed the Dark Knight which was
really inspired by crime to the Lords
like Heat and he's been on the record
pretty much saying that's what he took
inspiration from is genre splicing it to
make it a little bit different and not
just how do we repeat the beats from the
last movie per se if that makes any
sense yeah so yeah I think that's
probably the thing if you're not if
you're not willing to do that you got
this thing where you have producers and
then you have the creatives and you
never really know who is saying what and
who came up with what it's like
I was excited with James Cameron
producing and it seemed like Tim Miller
with the Terminator wanted to honor the
first two but then he ended up just
taking from the first two and then
adding some different spins on it I
don't really know like that's why I like
the last Jedi if I'm being totally
honest it's like the force awakens was a
good soft reboot with new faces that
reminded us of the old and they were
killing off some old characters and in
the last Jedi I thought
these did different things and took it
in directions that were not expected and
I and I feel like most franchises aren't
brave enough to attempt that I'm curious
what Wonder Woman's gonna do because
Wonder Woman has a very specific film
that took place in a very specific
decade and then there was a Wonder Woman
now there's Wonder Woman 1984 which by
its title alone and then the few
glimpses we've got it has to be an
entirely different kind of movie right
and I think that's the way you keep
franchises alive is not by just trying
to explain more of the origin but when
you really do feel like you can take it
in different directions like the purge
franchise is something that really bums
me out it's like how come the only thing
people do is kill people on the day
where you can commit crime like I'd love
to see like a heist movie in the purge
franchise no I'd like to see some weird
comedy in the purge world of where some
guy like accidentally dick someone over
and then he's like oh my god he's gonna
come after me on purge day yeah I gotta
stay away from you know some like weird
cat-and-mouse game I think you could do
like totally different weird things but
there's movies like like the a lot of
times these franchise is the the thing
that they have that they go wrong with
is they're they have a world but then
they don't do anything different within
the containment of their story and I
think killing off legacy characters is
not the solution it can be it's just do
it I think the best kind of like dread I
think is a great example of the kind of
movies you can do even though if didn't
do well box-office wise it's a big world
that tells a self-contained story and
that's kind of what that like you know
we keep talking to Terminator but the
questions stem from Terminator I think
it's what makes Terminator 1 & 2 so cool
is it's a big world that tells a
self-contained story and I think a lot
of times these franchises don't know how
to tell fresh self-contained stories and
that's where you got to go with telling
your new or movies I think with all
these franchises well yeah and I feel
like a lot of the recent ones
these attempts at rebooting have
borrowed a lot of the iconography and
images from their source material but
they neglect to the themes because
that's not sexy but I feel like if you
look at the recent Terminator or even
other ones that have been better like
dr. sleep and stuff like that it seems
like the level of filmmaking whoever's
funding these things want them to exist
on is a different type of film than the
original you know source material was so
I mean you know if we're talking about
like a slasher franchise yeah it's kind
of the same thing throughout with some
deviations here or there but you know
you come out of
it's like you have Terminator and
Terminator 2 which are two different
movies you have alien and aliens which
are two different movies and then after
that we kind of just take all the cool
action and the cool imagery and try and
remix those in fun and interesting ways
and they often fall short of fun and
interesting because they don't bother to
draw from the thoughtfulness of those
films or the tension of those films it
seems like they want to especially with
the new Terminator it seemed like they
wanted to deliver us an action
rollercoaster that had nothing on its
mind in terms of character relationships
it's like if you think it back to
Terminator 2 yeah the action is there
it's cool it's sci-fi it's awesome but
we all love like the thumbs-up and like
the relationship between Arnold and John
Connor or you know Sarah Connor and all
like there's so much character yeah and
I feel like you watch these more recent
reboots and even dr. sleep did this
where I felt like it wanted to exist on
an it remake level and the Kubrick film
which it's clearly going out of its way
to acknowledge is not at all that kind
of movie and it has a totally different
pace and a different sensibility and I
don't think that it's bad to break away
from that but I feel like if we're going
to keep these franchises going you have
to tap into the sensibility that made
them what they are and also with these
legacy characters it's hard because you
have to really commit I feel like they
it's really a bummer that we seem to
think three films at a time now instead
of one because I think that also slights
your new characters like the most
underperforming like the most
underdeveloped character in Terminator
dark fate is the new
who character is supposed to take on the
resistance it's the most afterthought
you know under written character in that
movie and so I don't know I mean you
have yourself into a corner because you
have the legacy you have these people
who we've had time to attach to to
associate with these roles to fall in
love with those performances and you
cannot duplicate those things and so it
comes down to these lightning in a
bottle scenarios where you have to cast
somebody terrific and you have to have a
role that is pretty needy for them to
sink into otherwise you know it's just
gonna feel like an exercise in keeping
the money flow going well you have two
kinds of franchises usually you have
like I think okay yeah like a die hard
okay which is what makes that work is
the character it's not really the world
of die hard it's not you know like oh
what is this crazy fictional world that
John McClane lives in and we could
branch how to make a cinema like they're
they're basically the worlds where it's
the character and then there are the
worlds where it's the big appeal of it
is the world around the character and so
like Indiana Jones cannot exist without
Indiana Jones diehard cannot exist out
John McClane and when they get too old
you can the franchise like Blade Runner
I could see how they can pick that up it
can continue because Blade Runner is
this massive sci-fi world that you can
continue it without Harrison Ford
needing to be in it and so that's that's
one thing that you have that they they
you got a factor in with a lot of these
movies it's the same it's like we're
talking about continuation or remakes
it's like I know you often reference the
Point Break remake as your go-to for
will makes the Point Break original work
is Patrick Swayze and Keanu Reeves in
those roles and a lot of those
franchises are married to that you can't
remake diehard with someone else
you can't continue diehard with someone
else
factor matters Bruce Willis just doesn't
care anymore so and if you want to you
can call it Olympus's follow yeah and
have somebody else be in it and has a
similar movie but not the same it's
really the best way to do it but if we
look at a lot of the
longest-lasting Frank fast and furious
is interesting because it's I feel like
it's close to running out of steam I
feel like it's close to running out of
fuel yes I feel like what what does that
make sense my breakdown on there you go
that makes an information superhighway
gas what are you making fart jokes okay
so yeah like fast and furious was a very
specific kind of franchise for movies in
and then they completely took it a
different direction by the fifth one and
then they really hone in on that and
then the Gary's new life into the
franchise bumblebee is probably the best
example I can give of a bigger world
with a self-contained story oftentimes
that's the best solution is just telling
new self-contained story really yeah I
feel like a lot of these franchises
allowed you the means to do that and
people just don't necessarily take it's
like Star Wars is another excellent
example where I feel like perhaps one
might argue with the reception of the
prequels and then the kind of way
Vorenus of the new installments you know
maybe we kept the Skywalker thing going
a bit too long yeah you know and and
yeah there's so many it's like we're
watching the Mandalorian now and it's
and there are tons of other Star Wars
shows that prove like yeah we don't need
these core people to make this
interesting it's a whole there's endless
possibilities that's a show I mean
because Star Wars is like I was talking
about that's that's a world world
franchise or universe franchise and not
a just about Luke Skywalker you know you
got you got something like I like John
wick is something I think I can see how
you can do a Continental show I can see
how you can do that because they've
built a world around John wick if it was
just what makes it's like I don't think
you know Olympus has fallen I know that
you can make a world within the Olympus
has fallen universe no they're both
badass the use of the guns you can kick
a lot of ass but you can't do that but
John wick you can so let's go back to
this question for a second when should a
franchise stop being a franchise I think
it's when
I I don't think it's possible to run I
think you can people milk stuff all the
time and if you're not willing to if you
can't come up with ways to tell this
story in a completely new or different
way then then don't do it like unless
unless but sometimes just wiggle room
for that sometimes I'm just repeating
that works you know like the rocky
franchise thrives really well off of
doing the same kind of thing over over
again it'll always come down like you
can make anything good if you put enough
time effort and care into it and so yeah
I mean there are franchises that have I
mean one of my favorites and this is
kind of a weird example to pull here cuz
it's not like a blockbuster franchise
but like the before trilogy is all the
same thing this is two people talking a
bunch but each time you know a check-in
or Evil Dead it's like Evil Dead checks
in at different points in Ash's life and
he uses that to its advantage even
though a lot of the elements and a lot
of the hijinks are based on the same
things but that's what I mean there's
evil dads willing to evolve it's
franchise like if you watch the first I
think if you watch if you start watching
ash vs. Evil Dead and then you go and
like you know what I want to know more
about this I'm gonna go watch the
original like so serious and slow like I
think it would communicate that way it
is someone who is coming off of the more
recent iterations of Evil Dead but that
franchise has greatly evolved into
something that was just full-blown weird
demented twisted horror into full-on
horror comedy and they've managed to
make that works and transformers went
from big giant spectacle weird you know
what it is and then into this like sweet
80s heartfelt movie about a girl and her
transformer you know but if you just
want to keep repeating and that's what I
mean by the fast and furious it's like
okay you guys need to do something
different now you need to do something
new because I'm now what was exciting
and fun and the best escapism is now
tiresome there's a high year some
there's a reason we're so excited about
this new saw movie is because you know
like the first seven saw movies are all
kind of delivering on the same idea same
world same continuing story and now you
have this prospect of somebody else is
coming in with a totally new take on
this and that at least breeds excitement
because it's the unknown and I feel like
a lot of franchises sell you the promise
of the known we love Easter eggs and we
love nods and things like that and I
don't think that that is in and of
itself bad but I've started to feel like
lately yeah it is kind of these delivery
systems and ways to keep rights and
stuff and yeah I don't know you just you
got to embrace the creativity because
you wouldn't have these originals
without the risk I feel like that's the
problem is the risk aversion makes it so
that they have this thing they know is
successful so you want to keep it going
but you don't want to change it because
that might be unsuccessful and so I feel
like it's a really weird place to come
from now because the only way we got all
these things were still aping is by
taking chances on them well you know
it's weird because this whole question
like especially the latter part is about
is it hard to have the legacy characters
around and developer character they can
step out of their shadow and stand on
their own literally the the franchise
that comes to mind that has done it the
best is Creed hmm like Creed one had
rocky your legacy character as the
supporting character who really shine
got an Oscar nomination and then has
successfully handed off this franchise
to a new player and like Rocky's barely
in Creed 2 he's supposedly not going to
be at all in Creed 3 and I'm ok with
that
yeah which is kind of weird no like I've
gotten to the point where I'm okay
without rocky being in this now better
to film handoff yeah and I'm sure he'll
be at least alluded to I mean I think it
would have worked just as well if at the
first five minutes of Creed they just
took a shotgun or rocky and a restaurant
yeah that's why he's fighting this time
is to avenge Rocky's death exactly no
it's not fighting the guys just as well
yeah
one hey you know in ten more years we
can watch Michael B Jordan hand the
franchise off to somebody else and see
if that works
yeah I think there's also something like
there are different kinds of movies
because like Creed is also we haven't
had it like when Creed came out we
hadn't had like a rocky in at least a
few years like we'd had Rocky Balboa a
number of years before but that's a
genre where it's like every time one of
those comes around I feel like it's kind
of on its own because we don't get a
huge amount of like boxing movies or
racing movies with like Ford Weaver re
out now which is not a franchise but you
know I feel like Terminator or or even a
doctor sleep is the kind of movie that
has a lot of similar movies around it
well I'm telling you I'm a I keep going
back to the same point everyone says the
best Terminator since Terminator 2 is
the Sarah Connor Chronicles I have not
seen the Sarah Connor Chronicles but I
can imagine that for the fact that it
was a network show and not this
overblown movie yeah that it's probably
a really good self-contained story had a
world character stuff yeah to make up
for all that time they can't do actually
exactly and I think that's why Creed was
successfully successfully work because
you really got to know the characters I
think the problem a lot of these bigger
franchises especially the ones that
really revolve around the world I mean
you couldn't you couldn't do Rocky 7 and
call it would then have Creed be the
main character you had to have called it
Creed and I think with films like Star
Wars or Terminator or whatever you know
the thing that they get bogged down by
is they want to explain more origin they
want to explain more of the world but
they don't put enough time into really
getting you to latch on to the new
characters because they're trying to get
to the action they're trying to get to
the more world building they're trying
to do all these things instead of going
well the main thing we just got to care
about is the characters right like that
it's it's the it's like rule number one
and story to tell you could see it's the
most basic rule pushes make you really
invested in the characters journeys and
less about plot and twists and surprises
none of that really matters in them in a
cliche movie if you love the characters
really it's that simple and I think
that's like what most of these
franchises get bogged down by his style
world-building origin explanation and
when I'm like we know we don't we don't
need less expansion on that and more
telling on the emotional stakes of these
characters and that's all you really
need really all you need to keep his
franchise fresh yeah and I feel like a
lot of times I get the sense that
whoever's making these movies kind of
forgets that yeah we we care because
this is a popular franchise clearly
there's interest but I think they forget
to make us care about the characters
every time I think they just assume like
oh you know who these people are you
know roughly what the world is so you're
already invested and that's not
necessarily true you need to reinvest us
every movie mm-hmm you know and as long
as you're gonna keep things going like
that
I saw something earlier this year that
made me think and it's again it's not a
franchise but like that movie crawl
could have easily been completely
forgettable and it's really
straightforward it's just a you know
horror thriller set in one environment
but what makes that movie work is that
the characters are written enough and
the actors are invested enough in them
that it elevates the entire experience
and I feel like if that little movie
could do that a lot of these big
franchise movies kind of have no excuse
because it shouldn't be that hard to
give us a few character bits that are
actually lived in and not just here's a
glance at my family photo or something
like that like I feel like there's a lot
of one line or one moment you know save
the cat style character development and
it's like wow we care moving on and it
doesn't really work well I you gotta let
the name go like the guy lets skywalker
go gala the Bourne name go honestly
Bourne Legacy is a fine movie and it
could have worked and it could have been
its own trilogy or whatever it just
didn't have anything to do with Jason
Bourne real like it's little
acknowledgement of Bourne is fine but
calling it the Bourne Legacy without
born in there is a big reason why that
phrase but that movie specifically
doesn't work
because you put a very specific
expectation on an audience member
your most of your audience at that point
you want to see Jason Bourne show up you
want a you want the same kind of movie
you essentially want a Bourne part for
at that point when that wasn't what it
wanted to do it wanted to do its own
thing and then it got bogged down by
that Bourne Legacy makes it sound like
Matt Damon's gonna hand it off to Jeremy
Renner in the movie yeah like not just
be like oh you're another agent from the
same program and then his legacy is
affecting you and I think that's part of
what kind of can its I'm not overly
concerned because they've been so
consistent since part three is Mission
Impossible but a big part of what's made
Mission Impossible so fresh is they kept
changing directors now the last two have
been the same director and as much as I
loved fallout I also was there going and
in a lot of ways this is like the
greatest hits of the last few
installments and they do it really well
they execute it very well and there is a
lot of tension and a big part of what
makes those songs work so well of course
is Tom Cruise really being in camera
doing all these crazy stunts but the
fact that he's doing two more movies
back to back with the same director it
does I'm not a hundred percent sold on
it because fallout was the first time
they ever had a director come back for
the following installment and I was like
this is great it is but there's a lot of
the greatest hits yes fresh yeah yeah
yeah I love it but it's yeah I still
preferred rogue nation over it it's like
the action I think is better and fallout
but you know what I mean so yeah I think
I Mission Impossible is unless it's like
Mission Impossible you can hand that off
to someone if they're willing to do what
Tom Cruise is willing to do yeah you
gotta find another daredevil who's gonna
put their life on the line because
there's totally a world there absolutely
that you could toy with and he inherited
the franchise from a totally other cast
yeah but you you need
you need an actor who's willing to do
all the things that Tom Cruise was
willing to do - and that is not easy to
[ __ ] a people so yeah you know just do
we answer the question in this thirty
minutes I think I think we have rightt
lot of ideas and you're not writing your
script you're just kind of focused
grouping it maybe you should take a
break
alright guys well one should a franchise
end comment below you can subscribe to
the real rejects click that notification
bell and hey check us out on patreon
Mykleby thank you dudes so much I hope
you have a happy Thanksgiving
if I were you I know you've been with
your girlfriend for a while what would
be a lot of fun is you can pressure her
into this saying like if you want to
show how grateful you are that I am your
boyfriend here's what you can do you can
commit the act of gluttony like Kevin
Spacey in seven and just fatten her up
just just shove down a whole bunch of
food and then cook her in the oven and
then to eat her afterwards that's true
love that's a way to keep someone with
you forever that yeah it's the until you
digest them
oh yeah but for the most part they are a
part of you they'll take some nutrients
and some protein yeah some things like
that some bone marrow is good for you
eat your girlfriend this holiday season
gobble gobble
take care